Do you know that there is a series on
Hulu called Tempest? There's a guy, he
pulls out a gun, he shoots this
politician who's a Republican
politician, a woman in white. Do you
remember Charlie Kirk's memorial? A
woman in white, an assassin walk into a
church. Kirk means church. [music]
The Kirks are Christian. Erica Kirk is a
Catholic. So here's this Catholic
church, this guy comes out, pulls a gun,
shoots.
Coincidence?
>> [music]
>> Jang Jin-ik of the New Republican Party
has been shot. Widow of South Korea
politician. Now we have a widow wearing
white of a Republican politician. To the
public, you're Joan of Arc. Joan of Arc
Kirk. Look at this. Joan of Arc Kirk
[music] refers to the conservative
commentator Charlie Kirk who was
assassinated in September 2025 and was
compared to Joan of Arc by right-wing
commentaries due to his prominent and
controversial stance on American
politics. I mean, how can there be so
many coincidences? In this movie, she's
a Christian, goes to Catholic church,
crosses, everything. I didn't know South
Korea had any Christianity, but I looked
it up, it's actually on the rise. When
did the Hulu show [music] Tempest
premiere? Oh, wait a minute. September
10th of this year. Wait a minute, the
very day the first episode which showed
the Republican politician get shot in
the neck in a church with a woman in
white who's actually going to take his
position. She takes his position,
premiered on September 10th, the same
exact day. In the show, she actually
gets a necklace from her husband after
he dies. It's her necklace, the husband
grabs it as he's dying, he bleeds all
over it, and [music] she doesn't see it
again until this guy brings it back to
her and gives her the bloody cross
necklace. Now check out what's going on
right now. Erica Kirk necklace. Erica
Kirk wears her husband's Charlie's
blood-stained pendant that was ripped
off from his [music] neck. Grieving
widow Erica Kirk has revealed she wears
a blood-stained pendant of Saint
Michael. That's very Catholic, by the
way. Charlie Kirk [music] is not who you
think he is. Of Saint Michael that her
husband Charlie was wearing when he was
shot. The small icon with blood traces
in the crevice of the cross
>> [music]
>> was ripped from Kirk's body. So she's
now wearing a blood-covered cross from
her husband who was shot in the neck on
September 10th, the same exact storyline
that's happening in the Tempest. This is
predictive programming, guys. Predictive
programming is Satan's counterfeit of
prophecy. God says, "I will not do
anything unless I reveal it to my
prophets first, right?" Everything he
does is in prophecy. So Satan
counterfeits everything that God does,
and he says, "Okay, God's got
prophecies, I got my own prophecies. I'm
going to put them in my Bible which are
the movies." Because all of these
movies' storylines are basically saying
that God is the villain and Satan is the
hero.